okay so yeah we're going to return
tonight to some of them more chopper
puzzle-like positions so we're going to
go over this game that was played
between Peter Svidler and magnus carlsen
from Norway chess 2014 we're going to be
going over defending really difficult
positions so sometimes in chess here you
get a worse position unless you're
really low rated then you skip having
worse positions and you go straight to
lost you just wonder all your pieces and
then it doesn't your net you never worst
you just go from equal to lost but you
know it's it is sort of an art just how
to defend when you're you know in really
tricky positions and so with that we'll
we'll pan slightly to the right and
we'll take a look at at this game here
so we'll go a few moves in so we can get
to the position but you'll notice in
this position black is much better so
Carlson has black he's playing Peter
Svidler the queen is really far away
from defending anything so you'll notice
black has all these pieces they can
quickly come in to the attack so so
scary stuff might happen and white might
have to defend really carefully what's
last move was Bishop to e3 which really
invited the move f4 which is a temporary
pawn sacrifice and he decided to accept
the challenge which is fine but okay you
probably don't put your Bishop on e3 to
move it back but moving the bishop also
was a safer option
okay Queen to h5
okay so then I went back to f3 and now a
very good decision by Carlson typically
he's very good when he's attacking he
played here the move Bishop to h3
trading the LightSquared bishop so that
then okay all the light squares are
gonna be weak around the King a very
good idea okay so he took and a nice
defensive move King to h1 he's going to
put his row congi one that could end up
being a very nice defensive maneuver
maybe he's going to get some counter
play along the G file and now again
another nice move and with this move not
only does he just get another piece into
the game so now we can use all of his
pieces but he's thinking immediately of
taking here and if you take back with
your Bishop you're a pawn is hanging so
Queen B 2 protects the pawn and another
idea behind rook e8 was this move e4
which really tears the board open you
know so he's if you don't either you're
going to take and you're your pawn
structure is going to be messed up or
I'm going to take and your F pawns will
be doubled and there'll be a lot of
extra space near your king he decided to
jump in to g5 which is only temporary oh
so close we almost got that door shut
because after the Queen retreats
he took here and then the next move was
Knight to g4 so the night went back to
f3 and okay there's quite a lot of good
moves here simplest perhaps is taking on
c4 now the material is equal again
assuming I know how to count and it
looks like I do it's four on to first
four on to five okay he gets his his
pawn back though after Queen to b3 and
rook takes e4 okay so now material is
equal
and we'll go just a few moves further
here and after this move here we will
pause and from this point on I'll see if
you guys can play like Peters fiddler
obviously this is a very tough position
you have to find a lot of only moves in
a row but here Karlsson actually made a
mistake and this can happen because okay
for example all of these captures are
really good and so sometimes it's
actually harder when you have four or
five moves that win then when you just
have one move that wins because when you
know there's only one move that wins you
just play that move but when there are
so many options you sometimes confuse
yourself and I mean I've just seen that
in so many games this just seems to
happen to people so if you're getting
you know attacked it's better that they
have a thousand ways to attack you
because maybe they'll they'll get
confused but for example just a sample
continuation if we take and deliver this
check and we bring our knight back out
to h3 this is just better for black I
mean Black is winning in this position
so this should be fairly elementary for
a world champion you know I mean I can't
imagine Carlsen losing this position but
he decided to get a little fancier and
he perhaps overlooked Fiddler's
defensive possibilities so in this
position he actually took on f4
the idea is if you take on f4 then okay
all these these pawns are hanging down
here so I can take on f2 and then I can
take on e2 so the question is now I mean
I mean taking on f4 is a move that we
must consider so would you guys take on
f4 or would you play some other move
some other move and so here I do want
you guys to take your time because it
will be pretty difficult to find some of
these moves and at home you may want to
pause your videos because whenever you
see stuff edited out it means these guys
got like five minutes to think about it
and at home you can take as much time as
you want
so joke would really be on you guys when
they take like 60 minutes analyzing this
that would show you because then they
know it better than you and I try I
could just keep talking with there's
positions on the board because then
Bensimon shows it and people at home get
to see the position for a little bit
longer but okay I'll give you guys a
couple minutes here and I will say one
thing that's very important when you
know you have these positions and you're
defending is to constantly be on the
lookout for blacks threats you know and
prophylactic thinking is just necessary
it's a must in positions like this so if
you ask yourself if it were blacks turn
to move I mean what is the threat in
this position rook takes Knight yeah
removing the defender of h2 and then
you're threatening checkmate so this
obviously we cannot allow I mean you're
taking the knight I just take back and
okay I'm winning stone
look you two okay and so your idea is if
I take your night you're still
protecting h2 very interesting so the
suggestion is rook to g2 again with the
idea that if I if you take the night
okay we have h to protected but I
suppose here one of these nights could
take and the idea is if you if you take
this I'm just taking back with a the
other night and I feel pretty pretty
confident here is black so this also was
it was a good try but it it doesn't
quite work is either so we return here
yeah
there we go yeah he did just take on f4
well that prevents the threat but
obviously it looks pretty dangerous now
I can I can take on f2 with check I can
take on e to all sorts of scary stuff
okay he took enough - and no points for
guessing what white played here yeah it
looks like a lot of hands went up yeah
they're all ready yeah this is lecture
is easy
kingi to push it ricky one as white if
you get another turn you get another
turn that's the most useful move you can
make all right all right he took on e2
okay very very scary stuff and again I
would urge you to think about what black
is threatening if you don't if you're
not paying attention to his threats you
won't be able to defend correctly what
is the most obvious threat that black
heads in this position yes this is this
is the most brutal this is just me but
yeah there are other moves like this
also mates this probably maids so I mean
but this is also definitely a threat
because you can you only go to f1 or h1
and in either case I take your knight
and then I made you so so this this must
be taken into account
I know in a world just in this position
just keep talking for you guys at home
I'll give you my my thoughts on Peters
fiddler
I think he's excellent and he's probably
the highest rated person that does like
Blitz banter on the Internet
and you're on the internet so you can
just go find that in it he is very very
resourceful
and an excellent defender I think that's
one of the things that he particularly
excels at and I mean I say it semi
jokingly and not uh not intended as an
insult or anything but he is somebody
that plays the Grune felt defense a lot
you end up getting you know worse
positions and you have to defend so he's
been an advocate of the Greenfeld and
you get a specific type of worse
position it's very special it's the type
where you also you know get complicated
sharp positions and a lot of chances to
muddy the water and even if you're
you're down you can confuse your
opponents and make things sharp he's
very good at that so if you watch a lot
of his blitz games even when he's behind
to a lower rated player he often makes a
big comeback because he's he's so good
at defending I think in that area he's
particularly resourceful so oK we've had
a little bit time does anyone have any
ideas okay so suggestion from the back
was Knight to g5 which has the the whole
point here is the I guess you're
defending f3 okay so I have some
discoveries I guess I'll play here
you're in check I think somebody
murmured the right answer a moment ago
ganging up one okay excellent and okay
and again this is very complicated but
now it's blacks turn he has to make a
big decision so right you having a good
sleep over there yeah okay where's this
going
and here the move the black plate might
surprise you why not just take the night
is the question so he did not take the
night yeah this is not yeah this is not
made but we will we will analyze this
variation rook g3 yeah this is a move
the White has to play in this position
and now black has two chances and this
wasn't the game but it is worth
analyzing if you take the bishop
well let's throw this check in first I
mean you on defending your pond and then
okay now we can take the rook and okay
we have we have such ideas and now it's
actually white that's playing for the
win all of a sudden so but also
complicated is if I if I just go here I
protect my pond now this move is
excellent this this is the challenge and
again try to see what black is
threatening and it's it's not obvious
so I mean Congrats if you you find the
best move here for black you know like
if I passed if I can play here well what
is blacks thread
yeah Bishop takes it okay so yeah that
would be that is always I mean you got
to calculate so many sacrifices and
stuff so before we can even begin to
understand though what the saving move
is here for white we have to understand
what blacks threat is which is in itself
a very difficult task okay so we haven't
sorry in this position quite found
blacks threat if you need more time at
home now's the time to pause your video
the surprising threat that Black has in
this position yeah my h3 all right at
the very at the buzzer Darren Turner at
the buzzer
excellent and yet the threat is rook up
to me notice how the knight is
protecting g1 so if fantastic so now we
know the threat and now we have to
figure out how to stop it yet again
yeah all right sometimes sometimes you
can see their their threat and then you
like I don't have to stop up but here
you can stop it beep well I'm trying if
you if you play here I'm trying to you
know checkmate you not trying to win
material I assume I can take your rook
but we got to ask our trusty friend over
here in the little deference
so it doesn't want it wants to play that
with protec XIII and then once you bite
Bishop takes and 94 yeah how am I so
good
how do I find all the answers yeah I
mean I'm just trying to crush you though
if you play this way you know I'm just
I'm trying to I'm just trying to crush
you yeah I suppose
hmm which which you guys got a
preference this one okay take the night
with the King yeah this is I don't even
need to take your Bishop maybe that's
the only thing to calculate is if I if I
need to take your Bishop or not but yeah
I mean you have something like this I
mean I assume I show this is great this
has to be great for me
okay so we're almost there we're almost
there
so in this position King f1 it's really
stressing it out there also somebody say
Queen d7 whenever we alright so we'll
return we haven't quite found it yet we
need to attack and also I mean going
here also it might be a possible move
for for black so we need to control
squares on a diagonal so we need that
Queen d7 was and now actually with best
play this should be a draw if you take
my rook which is the audience's biggest
fear I take your Brooke and I mean the I
can even part with this piece and with
best play there's just a perpetual here
so yeah if you found Queen d7 before we
had any hint something big congrats it's
a it's a tough move to find so but stuff
like that is in the position and it's
you know it's not beyond Carlson's grasp
to be able to calculate something like
that so you know is you can see these
sorts of things so he did not take the
knight in this position if you take the
knight with best play it's a draw he
instead played a cunning move Knight to
e4
again shocking the audience no one can
believe it and okay so some people see
the point the point is if I take this
rook you have this check that's the
point and I believe it was here though
that he perhaps didn't see what the best
defensive move was here I think he
underestimated or just didn't see what
the fiddler has in this position among
our threats where we can just take this
I mean we're probably also if you stop
that somehow we're probably also
threatening to put one of our Knights
here and check me you you know some we
have so many threats I mean the obvious
the obvious one is taking on f3 here
so we mustn't get checkmated above all
yes that's right to play the last move
was Knight to e4 awesome yeah yeah
exactly
yeah you take on g7 perfect and this is
okay white is playing sometimes there's
perpetual z' that's the sort of thing
that you want to be looking for and the
point is if you take the rook then I can
play Queen d7 which was not played in
the game he just sidestepped so we'll
come on to that if you go here well the
Queen comes in and you can trade the
Queen's now but for accuracy's sake and
we'll check here the point being that
okay if you want perpetual I'm fine with
that is white and if you want to go back
now your King is slightly farther away
accuracy and in this position you know
lots of stuff can be traded and black is
still a little bit better even though
his knights on b1 but this is no longer
you know what's what's the smash them up
knock out below that Magnus was looking
forward to this now is a very
challenging technical task to win this
position so this this would be a big
mistake so we can understand this this
tricky move that was played King f8 just
keeping the same threats in the position
and again we need to find the the only
move here for white
we know the thread Queen takes F 395
alright people seem to like to go to
this the square is this not my not
meeting you I mean I must I must be but
how
okay I got rid of your bishop so I can
just take it okay so yeah not quite
I'm sorry so we'll go back here after
King f8 rook f7
well I can just take right okay and I'm
not checkmating you but I'm winning some
of this stuff you can take my Brooke I
take your for show up this doesn't quite
work do you have an idea queen bee for a
little little check John what's the best
move here for black help everybody out
and say c5 that's the obvious answer
yeah so I need to get out and then just
didn't quite work I'm threatening your
queen and taking on f3 okay so after
King f8
and the surprising move that you can
play now it's a little bit different
than in the other position taking Newark
which obviously allows the fork and so
okay that all happened but this is a
slightly different position than what we
saw before the difference is the rook is
already on g7 so again we're looking for
the only move for white in this position
rook B to g1 excellent yeah fantastic
and now Carlsen actually made a mistake
the best move is it's just playing move
like night here and okay the knight
reroutes to e4 the White King will try
to live on g2 you know this should be
equal but here you play Knight to c3 and
what's funny is now
Spindler could have actually started to
play for the wind so I don't know if he
saw this next move and thought he was
better or you know maybe he saw it and
he's like I don't know maybe Mike Kings
on f2 and I got no pawns in front of it
and you might have thought that he was
just worse so he went for a line that
virtually secures the draw you want to
play here the best move yeah yeah and
after this you can take here if you go
here I'm I'm actually quite safe on g2
so surprisingly now it's the blacks King
that is in a little bit of danger but
one King is actually quite safe so white
in this position could be thinking about
playing for a win if you wanted to try
to win but obviously there's there's a
lot of room to make mistakes in this
position so so instead he took on c7
and after here it's White's turn to do a
little trick
he played King e1 dropping his Knight Oh
No
what's White's trick Bishop h6 yeah so
that's the little trick nice little
trick sorry so he took on c7 and after
nine to c5 the game ended shortly
they repeated draw so I mean swindler on
this game had to find so many only moves
it was so complicated it's so difficult
but very resourceful guy yeah he found
all the all the right ways to you know
fight for the draw in this position it's
not easy and ok I mean saving a half
point against Magnus Carlsen is not a
small feat it was very difficult and I
would like to show one more more for
amusement this this was hard and
difficult and hopefully educational but
this one will be for amusement
ok let's see alright so in this position
it's black to move and as you can see
we're under a little bit of pressure you
know white is thinking about about this
this sort of scenario and so I'll give
you guys a couple minutes here to think
about what you would do as black you are
worse and you are thinking about trying
to force a draw so I leave it to the
class yeah black is hoping to draw I
mean white has a very powerful attack
he's going to play rook g6
with with a lot of threats checkmate
being you know among them
yes so this was it so at home if you
haven't solved it you may want to pause
now you said pawn to eat one queening oh
okay so this did happen and you took
yeah the rope captured okay rook g6 I'm
threatening me this service okay we have
two different suggestions one is one is
better than the other yeah this this no
idea you check maybe where did these own
you want to go here okay
it's kind of nice that now you're not
going to check me here so I guess I move
and then the game continues but yeah I
was mentioned this check
okay this was playing the game alright
and maybe as we're getting closer here
we start to see what the little idea is
Arjun rook g1 excellent this roof d3
okay not here if here then I can go here
I don't see your your next check I just
assumed you two get it right because
your hard room okay this this check is
much better because now we have some
some follow-up checks rook takes a ch3
yes are we starting to see the idea we
have perpetual check where is it we we
got a couple of Queen checks here so
let's let's be careful Queen c3 you're
gonna check me from really far away I
know I mean every okay Queen f3 okay
sure seems reasonable enough I will go
here
you would do it now yeah this also sandy
origin would be there to help me out I
just do it okay so this doesn't quite
work or very close Quinta h1 okay I must
go here now do we do we see the idea
which check well I got two checks right
which one the one where the pawn doesn't
take you okay he didn't want me to take
his thing do I get to run run out a
little bit obviously if I start running
around and if I can end up back over
here in this general area maybe I can
protect myself with my pieces and so not
quite
yeah the other check yeah you want to go
where the pawn can take you all right
yeah we starting well we're starting to
see the idea Quinta yeah yes you'll
notice this King doesn't have a lot of
squares to go to and none of his pawns
can move so what's the move here Arjun I
think he he went to a different square
but yeah but Queen g2 is the same I
guess this is this was his preferred way
to get stalemated so going back just
look at the position one more time yeah
so is this position and if you noticed
right away that the King doesn't have a
lot of squares and you can try to get
rid of all your pieces and okay the
knight has to go here so that upon takes
and it keeps that pawn from moving so
okay that was an amusing using little
and these these players were both rated
about 2200 so okay I mean it's probably
not a very famous or well-known game but
it certainly certainly pleasing to watch
very very aesthetically pleasing I guess
I have little time should we go or
somebody's game yes yes all right for
you you can twist approved okay so we
did get another viewer submission I've
been getting so many so it's funny this
guy his name is Kyle he says hey
Jonathan and obviously he spelled my
name wrong which doesn't bug me but
what's funny is I just don't get it how
people they've always misspelled
Jonathan and they always spell France
right like surely Francis the hard part
but you know you know people like to put
an H in my name and they you know here
yeah I know any and I think what's wrong
like you have to actually like look at
it but oh how do I type that right and
Jonathan you just guess because there's
so many ways by which I don't have I
mean I don't care I mean but okay I'm
primarily a Queen's pawn player and I
find I have a lot of trouble with the
qgd and semi slop positions I was
wondering if he had had a look at this
game for me and he was white in this
position both of these players were
rated about 1450 ish and looks like so
the game in 15 this was played on chess
cube calm just cube yeah it's an
interesting site it's kind of cool
because you get like qubits and so you
can bet and wager on your games so it's
kind of cool in that respect I I was
playing it at the beginning but there
wasn't a lot of strong players so I just
stopped going there but I assume by now
it's it's even better but it's a pretty
cool idea alright so we get you know a
Queens gambit declined and my my
preferred move over here is Knight to c3
because sometimes the knight ng1
actually ends up going to e2 as seen in
my my lecture but okay obviously this is
not a mistake and they transpose now to
a semi Slav and white played the most
aggressive move Bishop to g5 and here
there's there's a lot of really
complicated ways that black can play so
you can take here very complicated
you could play h6 very complicated but
his opponent decided to play Knight B to
d7 in this position black can enter the
Cambridge Springs but he played a move
that I don't particularly like but I see
it quite a lot in in amateur games
Bishop to e7 I don't like it I mean it's
just it's it doesn't really fit with the
plan I think you should just take the
pawn play aggressive
yeah I mean it's it's kind of like the
Moran at some point I kind of want to do
this sort of thing to get this guy out
so I want to be like taking on c4 and
then whenever you move your Bishop and I
attack it this is going to be like a big
theme but unlike the Moran which would
be this position where that you know if
they if white plays Bishop to d3 you can
take on c4 this is just a little bit
different so the inclusion of these two
moves I think just favors white it's not
like a huge mistake or anything I just
don't I would prefer this move order
much more common in this position is
Queen to a5 that's the cambered Springs
the idea being to attack this Knight a
thousand times so that that tends to
happen and okay has white I like to play
here because it's the sharpest and not
as popular but Knight to d2 which takes
control over the e4 square is are very
sensible and white should get a
comfortable edge here for example after
this we can just protect our Knight and
you get a position like this and then in
amateur games they take here you take
back and the Queen takes us Bishop
that's that's how most games end but
okay we go we go back so that was not
played we got here okay
and he played Bishop to d3 which is fine
another option to is to play Queen to c2
and you're just waiting for this bishop
to move so as soon as this bishop moves
as he did in the game black can start to
consider taking on c4 and when you take
back we get some time to you know get
these pieces out and I'm gonna play here
and c5 and if I get to play all these
things then I'm feeling good
his opponent did not play that he did
something kind of interesting not good
but interesting Queen to b6
alright attacking the B pond so he
defended it yeah so I think if I was
playing a 1400 I would have tried this
move because it's trickier
and if if they take here what's the trap
94 trapping the Queen so they might fall
for that that's also tricky it's another
common way to defend your B pond in
certain situations like this but Queen C
- very good I mean I like White's
position here so far no major mistakes
and now black goes on a little bit of
hunt and white should certainly not mind
this i mean you know you want to push
those pawns fine I don't really know
where the King is going to go the black
King so I mean I wouldn't be pushing all
these pawns maybe I'd play h6 but not g5
yeah because I mean you're not really
safe on either and at some point in the
distant future I mean I want to get my
king safe but I can play eform really
open the center and try to attack you if
you don't never get Castle but he went
out a little bit pon and so far I think
white is as played very well and I like
his move in the game he castled and I
think yeah I think castling queenside is
the right idea because then when the H
file opens up as it did in the game you
know that's that's good for your rook on
h1 but also interesting in these types
of positions and this happens whenever
they push their H and G pawn and then
they put their knight on the side so
they can take your bishop it can happen
with either color an interesting idea is
often Bishop to e5 one idea being if you
okay I'm attacking a rook if you take my
bishop you bring my night to a great
square this guy your only job out there
was to take my bishop so you're gonna
have to take some time going back and I
think in a position like this we're
looking at at some tactics here now you
know so I'm starting to think about okay
I kind of played Bishop to g6 this sort
of thing and black can get into a lot of
trouble really fast so that is also an
interesting idea to keep in mind in
these types of positions but in the game
he castled which okay is fine
opening the you know you lost the two
bishops but you open up the H file and
he's pushed a lot of his pawns
and all right it's just it's pretty hard
for him to develop his pieces
comfortably whenever this night moves
then okay we can hop in here so it's
hard for black to do anything so he
decided to play here which is a big
mistake then let's see why yeah there's
a pin here on the itch file and this
wasn't seen by the player so that the
Jeep on is going to be hanging for
several moves now which we see a lot in
these games I mean okay it's just
something that has been overlooked but
yeah whenever there's these rooks here
you know now the bishop moved away I
mean we can we can take on one g5 so
more sensible for black would've been a
move like g4 because the knight moves
away and for some reason you want to put
your bishop on before then you could do
it but okay so this was this was
overlooked and king b1 okay I mean yeah
I mean okay that's fine but this is sort
of what happens in the next couple moves
here is why I wanted to talk about this
because I think this is truly
instructive at this point what both
players end up doing is whenever there's
the potential for a trade they just
trade so I mean here he just took the
knight which is gonna make John Boyer
leave the room he's so angry like why
would you think that there's really no
reason for it I mean bishops are better
than Knights and I think you play a lot
of bughouse and then it's opposite nice
or better but yeah but this is chess for
some reason oh okay but I think to why
people end up doing this because I think
this is sort of a normal human behavior
especially you know when you're you're
starting learning chess and whatever and
even people that have played for a long
time end up doing this whenever they can
trade they trade and I think it's just
because you get clarity you know what
your opponent's going to do you know you
know there's so much stuff I might get
confused you just want to simplify and
and you know but you do want to just
think sort of position
about what is what's going to happen
here you know you trade the bishop for
the night I mean I don't know why why
that's a good trade for black and we'll
see a lot of that so from from both
sides in this game a five here comes the
attack all I need is my pawn in my Queen
to attack you okay this this attack
doesn't have much of a chance especially
you know the King isn't situated and
black doesn't have enough pieces to go
launch an attack in here Knight to e5
which i think is a great mistake well
even if we don't see that we can just
win upon here because okay this is still
the best move I think again so white
just wants to trade which is which is
wrong and you want to think about it's
wrong for several reasons you kind of
want to think about how it affects the
position when you make this trade so
first of all I mean this Knight is just
better than this Knight so for that
reason you don't want to trade but also
white is is the one that's clearly
better in this position so if you've
assessed that white is better in this
position you don't want to simplify you
know you want to keep all the pieces on
the board because simplifying will only
help your opponent defend so after this
move I mean he took so they got they got
some clarity but it's not so obvious
that this is actually helped white in
any meaningful way I mean I don't know
this this position will be better than
keeping the knight on f3 all right here
comes the attack and he played a3 which
is no big mistake but I probably would
have let him play a3 and then I played
b3 I think that's the best way of just
keeping the Queen side closed but this
is no mistake and so here again black
just wants to trade and in the game they
just traded Queens but still I think
white is better so I would just try to
keep the Queen's on the board and what's
funny is Mike comer gave somebody a
lesson here a private lesson and he's
like yeah I always trade always trade
and then I taught the same person I said
yeah I'd never trade never
trade and now Danny is sort of of the
same philosophy but he's not here so he
doesn't have a chance to defend himself
would be unfair to to make fun of him
too much a little bit and yes I mean
anyone you're better you just don't want
to trade but he did in this game and
again I guess they just can't help it he
trades again and so you want to be
thinking too about what is the
consequences of taking first of all I
mean he's not really threatening to do
this so if you want black wants to play
that move that's fine because then okay
I'm on your beep on and it actually it
gives a chance to one of two things is
going to happen we can take either way
and so this is sort of an important
question I think you know for certain
players in the audience is sort of an
obvious choice which way to take back
but you want to think about the
consequences of what's going to happen
so a lot of the times when you play
chess and pawns are traded files are
opened up so in the game he took this
way which is incorrect now the C file is
open so that's sort of the positional
consequence of this move and if white
wants he can be the first one to make it
to the C file so this could have
happened
conversely if you take this way
well now the diagonal that the bishop
was on is open so you can develop this
guy somewhere don't go too far but so
somewhere in the red zone and you see
file is not open so okay but in the game
he took this way and e4 to trade some
more stuff but here in this position I
think taking a d5 is the right idea and
again if we just think about the
positional consequences of taking on d5
we see he gets an isolated pawn that's
something that we might be able to
target I already got a rook looking at
the pottage guy get the bishop out of
the way so I think this was the right
decision to take f4 should be fine the
King bought up the rooks are connected
and black still has problems you know
such as it's hard to move this guy
that's still an issue so white is still
just clear
a much better and I like this move
coming up I guess it's not here
so here at black actually makes a big
positional mistake
what did black play
yeah G for that one that would have been
better yeah what what what would be the
worst move you could possibly play f6
was played and okay now after this this
is very favorable for white because now
we have a protected passed pawn so I
think I think what he was worried about
is f6 like white playing it himself but
after I'm sorry after a move like rook
to a4 if he plays this I want to play
the move that will frighten the class I
want to play here I'm not I'm not afraid
it looks like maybe okay you protect
this and you play here and here only
that doesn't work because I got my rook
here so I can take this thing so
something like this would have been okay
for black but this certainly is just a
big mistake and boy it's much better
again so very good and here I do like
White's move here he improved his pieces
so the bishop rima new vers to f3 this
this was a very good decision and so
even if black is thinking i can sack
this pawn get some activity that'll
that'll all be squashed when Bishop f3
lands on the board we're okay for yes
excellent okay and what is is on top
again and in the game we got we got this
blunder I suppose because my D pawn is
no attack toys that I would protect it
but four times think here we're running
short on time we'll just look at what
happened in the game and okay white
played sort of the obvious move and
unfortunately we're gonna have to speed
through this yeah in in okay and now
what happened also is funny g4 is funny
here because it's almost subjoin you
know almost it's hard for black to move
anything but you can move this beep on
but in the game rook b5 okay we're going
to go win your pawns
and so so one this and now black made
another mistake he went here to make
sure he trade all the rooks which wasn't
fortunate and then all the rooks came
off and black resigned so the one
takeaway from this game I think is when
you're making trades you do want to
consider what the consequences are and
you want to think about how it changes
the position what pieces are being
traded
how are you changing the pawn structure
all these sorts of things make a big
difference and when you have the better
position you really want to keep the
pieces on the board because your pieces
are better than their pieces and when
your pieces are better than their pieces
you shouldn't trade them